Professor John Merriman:
Okay, today we're going to
talk about Paris.
And in order to talk about
Paris in the Belle
Époque--and the Belle
Époque was not good for
most people in France,
as we heard before,
but the image of that nostalgia
infused a vision of Paris in the
Belle Époque is something
that of course comes--really is
created,
it's imagined,
after World War I.
But in order to understand sort
of the cultural,
and economic,
and political,
and social dimensions of fin de
siècle of Paris,
we have to back up and look at
the rebuilding of Paris in the
1850s and '60s by that man
dissed by my late friend,
Richard Cobb,
as the Alsatian Attila,
that is Baron Haussmann,
whose name I should've written
on the board but didn't.
Some of you already know about
him, but it's h-a-u-s-s-m-a-n-n,
Georges.
And he only went back to Paris
three times after he left in
financial scandal at the end of
the 1860s.
And he lives until the early
1890s, but the great boulevards
that became identified with
modern Paris and on which Emile
Henry went on this little walk,
going out to kill,
have to be seen in the context
of the rebuilding of Paris
during that period.
And it was the largest urban
renewal project in,
at that time,
in the history of cities.
Really, the only ones
comparable were the rebuilding
of Edo, that is Tokyo,
after the Great Fire,
and London, at the time of
Christopher Wren.
So, we back up even further to
look at Paris in 1837,
just to give you a sense of
what changed.
And the first thing you notice,
particularly if you're
comparing it to London or to
Berlin, is how small Paris was
and how small Paris still is.
This is pre-1860,
so it's before the inner
suburbs were annexed,
which included Montmartre out
there, and Auteuil,
and all of the others.
And those of you who've been to
Paris or know about Paris will
see the Jardin de Luxembourg
there,
which was very,
very close to the city limits
at that time,
and then there is the
Tuileries,
and then the edge of Paris
there, the Arc de Triomphe,
which was begun by Napoleon and
completed during the July
Monarchy.
So Paris, a tremendously
overcrowded place--and the most
densely populated parts of Paris
until mid-century were the
Île of Cité,
that is the Island of Cite,
c-i-t-e;
there's Notre Dame,
and the Marais,
m-a-r-a-i-s,
the sort of central Right Bank
districts;
and their population density is
three times what it is today.
And, so, the population of
Paris, which grows so rapidly,
in 1851 is 1,053,000 people;
1861, a year after the
annexation of the inner suburbs,
is 1,696,000;
1872 after the Commune
1,825,000, minus the 25,000
people slaughtered in the wake
of the Commune,
during bloody week;
1881,2,269,00,
and 1896 about two and a half
million people.
And, so, European cities only
grow basically in the first
two-thirds of the nineteenth
century through migration,
because more people die in
cities than are born there--why?
Because of unhealthy
quarters…
The life expectancy in Lille,
for example,
was about nineteen-years-old,
the same thing in Manchester.
That includes infant mortality,
so that's a little bit skewed;
but, still, cities are
unhealthy places.
Old people, the miserably poor
people also go to Paris to try
to find charity and ultimately
to die.
Child abandonment,
infanticide and all the things
that I mentioned
before--disease,
the cholera disease rips
through Paris in 1832 and 1849,
again in 1884.
So, basically cities,
large cities replenish
themselves only through
immigration, through much of the
nineteenth century.
And, so, what happens is you've
got this sort of super,
hyper overcrowding of the
central districts as immigrants
from the north of France,
from Normandy,
from the east of France,
also seasonal migrants from the
Limousine who finally settle
Paris pour into these central
districts and then gradually
head for the edge of the city.
It's not until the 1880s that
you have the huge wave of Breton
migration from Brittany;
and it's not just to Paris,
also, but that comes later than
we're talking about.
So, you've got your basic,
extraordinarily crowded city,
the ranks of the poor,
above all, swollen by
immigration.
The difference,
one of the differences between
the nineteenth century and now,
for example,
is in the nineteenth century
most people, the people coming
into Paris were already poor,
were poorer than the people who
were already there.
Now, in the 1950s and 1960s
that changes,
the 1950s and 1960s.
You have les jeunes
couples, you have young
married couples,
upwardly mobile,
who come to Paris with enough
money that they've put together
to rent and then finally maybe
to buy an apartment,
et cetera, et cetera.
But you have a mass of poor
people, masses of poor people
coming into Paris,
and Paris is unhealthy.
This I put in,
this is rien à
voir avec,
but this is--I've said before
about how you just try to
imagine what things are like
until you can see actually for
the first time--this is the
first photo of Paris.
This is a daguerreotype;
it was a primitive kind of
photo.
You can identify this as the
Rue--as the Faubourg du Temple
on the edge of Paris,
and this is 1837.
But here is your classic sort
of image of urban poverty,
urban squalor,
the kind of grey images of a
street that no longer exists
because of Haussmann's
rebuilding.
This is behind the
Panthéon,
that is just sort of above the
Latin Quarter,
and you see this ditch running
right down the street.
It carried sewage.
There were already sewers in
Paris, but it was terribly
unhealthy--and you're thinking,
"oh, why?"--he says,
"it's so crowded but where are
all the people,
it looks like there's nobody
there."
Well, in fact it's because it
took so long to expose photos
that they're--as you look very
closely you can see some people.
But another reason why there
are not a lot of people about or
any signs of life is that this
has already been targeted for
demolition,
and the people have had to move
out of what was already a poor
neighborhood to find an even
poorer one on the margins of
urban life.
That was a photograph by
Charles Melville.
And here we got the Louis
Napoleon, your basic picture of
Louis Napoleon,
for once not at the opera
trying to hit on the young
ballerinas,
and the man in the middle is
Haussmann, who was not born in
Alsace, but his family came from
Alsace and he'd been a law
student in Paris,
and he was born in the more
prosperous western part of
Paris.
Again, that dichotomy between
prosperous west and more
impoverished east is as
important as increasingly
prosperous center,
over the long run of time,
and the impoverished periphery,
more about that in a minute.
So, in 1852 Napoleon spreads
out a map of a city he really
didn't know very well,
Napoleon III does,
and says, "I want you to build
me great boulevards."
And, so, Haussmann,
who's prefect of the Seine,
does that.
And it's a time when the
wealthy got wealthier and the
poor did better,
working class people did
better,
but the gap between the rich
and the poor increased.
So, now, if you're looking
later, in 1855 you see that the
city had expanded but you still
have the wall around Paris and
you still have these sort of
rural areas within the city.
And one of the points of this
is that there's a continuing
implosion of population into
Paris,
and the eviction by high prices
and by demolition,
with the rebuilding of Paris,
is going to push people out
into the working class
periphery.
Belleville, which I talked
about before,
that's where Emile Henry says
"it's war between you and me
now, baby";
La Villette;
Montmartre here,
which was indeed still at this
time fairly rural.
Oh well, you have to just all
move your heads to see,
this is not a very interesting
photo,
but--or it's not hardly a
photo, but just to see the
difference between 1850 and
1900,
the growth of the suburbs.
And so this all involved the
demolition of great hills.
This was a hill at Trocadero,
which is right on the Seine,
and it put tens of thousands of
workers--gave them something to
do.
Now, the principle of this,
of the planning itself,
and this impacts this course
and the Paris of this course,
is really built upon classical
principles associated with
absolute monarchs;
and I call it the imperialism
of the straight line,
in that if you think of a city
like St.
Petersburg, built by Peter the
Great, or if you think of
Madrid, built by Phillip II,
or you think of Berlin and
Frederick the Great,
or you think of Versailles,
a rather prosperous suburb,
they were power alleys down
which you marched troops,
and very different than the
kind of organic city that had
grown up from medieval origins,
a city like Strasbourg or,
for that matter,
Lyon, though Lyon has some
classical touches too in the
Place Bellecour,
and all of that.
But here, just to give you an
obvious and almost banal
example, but I chose it because
you already know about the
Avenue of the Opéra,
for reasons we talked about
before, is that this is pure
imperialism with a straight
line.
The
problématique,
or the question,
is how you get--you're going to
build this big boulevard,
how do you get from the Seine,
basically--here's the Rue de
Rivoli paralleling the Seine,
to where you're going to build
this new, magnificent opera that
you saw before?
Well, you don't have to be an
architectural genius,
or Vincent Scully or someone
like that,
you simply take a ruler and
then you tip off your friends
about where the building's going
to go,
so they make a lot of money,
and that's what Haussmann did,
and then you plan the Avenue de
l'Opéra.
And there are three reasons,
three, why Paris is rebuilt.
First, to bring more light and
air to Paris,
to make it a healthier
place--more sewers and all that;
second, to free the flow of
capital, for capital,
to help business.
It's not a coincidence that the
big department stores that grow
up in the '50s and '60s are on
the grands boulevards,
are on the big boulevards;
and third, and I've alluded to
this before, how do you build a
barricade across a huge
boulevard,
how do you build a barricade
across the Avenue de
l'Opéra?
The first barricades in Paris
were in the late sixteenth
century.
You know about the barricades,
at least some of you do anyway,
of the French Revolution.
There are more barricades in
1830, there are more barricades
in 1851.
You've seen photos of
barricades from 1871.
And Haussmann says this in his
memoirs, "we want to create
barricade-proof boulevards."
In World War II,
in August of 1944,
the barricades that are built
against the German troops are
built in neighborhoods often
where you have narrow streets.
And in 1968 it's the same thing.
It was very hard to build a
barricade across the Boulevard
Saint-Michel.
So, that's the first thing.
And then you imagine you're
looking down--you're looking at
Garnier's Opera,
which is going to rise out of
the ground, the most expensive
building built in Paris to that
point,
and then these houses,
which were actually fairly
middle class buildings,
have to be demolished.
So, you are in--you were
sitting in a bulldozer looking
through the smoke,
and then there is Garnier's
Opera being built,
and there is Garnier's Opera,
right here.
And, of course,
that square now contains
probably the largest population
of pickpockets this side of the
Spanish steps as American
tourists get off the metro there
looking for American Express
with their wallets about to be
soon to disappear.
But, and here you can look down
and see--this is reversed but it
doesn't make the slightest bit
of difference--you can see
that's the Place Vendôme,
the column of which was brought
down in 1871 at Courbet's
suggestion.
And, so, you end up with this,
which you've already seen
before, the Avenue de
l'Opéra,
and it was down here,
the first bomb that Emile Henry
placed was down here at number
eleven.
And, so, this is again a photo
from 1900.
So, this is basically--there
are a few automobiles racing
around;
they're not racing,
the speed limit was three miles
an hour;
but now, of course,
you're a dead duck if you try
to cross there.
There was somebody,
some general who was arrested,
some scandal and he just had
testified,
and then he wasn't thinking,
and he walked out into the
street and was run over by a
bus.
So, you really kind of have to
watch it there.
But here's your pure sort of
Haussmann vista of Paris.
And, of course,
the balconies,
the sort of ornate balconies of
the Third Republic are something
that one identifies with the
grandeur of modern Paris,
the Paris of the Belle
Époque.
Now, what about the people who
were chased from the central
districts?
This is not a very interesting
print, but it's still--it was
sympathetic to those people.
Most people didn't own
apartments, they rented,
and if you were kicked out of
your apartment in order to
facilitate the building of these
boulevards,
you were given the equivalent
of about a day's wages and that
was it.
And here you have--this is part
two, these are two lithographs,
and the first is called
Haussmannization of--that
is the bulldozing of,
the Haussmannization of
Paris, part one,
where you see these people and
they've got everything that they
have--they got their dog and
it's a sympathetic look at them;
and this is part two,
and this is a pure Haussmann
vista.
This is very near the
Opéra,
this is the Church of
Saint-Augustine,
which I think is just
god-awful,
but here again you have again
the imperialism of the straight
line.
And this is the big commercial
district, this is where the big
department stores are near
there,
like the Gallery Lafayette,
and at this time the Grand
Magasin d'Louvre,
and all these sorts of things.
So that's what--that's the
principle of Haussmann.
Well, you can hardly see that.
So, if you were a bird flying
around up here then,
or if you're in a balloon and
you're seeing the results of
Haussmann, here again you've got
Notre Dame,
which goes from the most
populated part of Paris,
along with the Marais,
to the least populated part of
Paris.
Why?
And we talk a lot about the
State, but these state buildings
or state constructions,
including the big hospital,
Hotel Dieu, or the Prefecture
of Police are built on
Cité,
and so the population departs.
This over here is the Church of
Saint-Sulpice,
which had one of the great
organs,
and here this is the famous
market of Les Halles which was
built at this time next to the
Church of Saint-Eustache,
and it lasted until 1972,
and they wouldn't--and they
tore them all down and built
this sort of miserable failure,
three floors of crummy
electronics stores,
and they didn't even leave one
so people--I sound like Scully
but it's true,
they didn't leave just one so
people could see what it was
like, what was the market.
And I was lucky because the
first time I ever was in Paris,
when I was a kid,
somebody took me down there in
the middle of the night and you
could see the butchers drinking
with very sort of
friqué,
very prosperous clients eating
at a big table next to there.
And it was fantastic,
it was the guts of Paris,
it was the heart of Paris,
and they just destroyed it.
And they had to move the market
out by Orly Airport because
Paris is so big,
with eleven million people in
the region now.
But it didn't make any sense to
destroy them all,
it was such vandalism,
just incredible,
and it came at the time of
Pompidou, who said that "we must
renounce this outmoded
aesthetic";
that is, anything that was
beautiful and interesting,
and he was a patron of art,
of modern art in all its worst
forms.
But, anyway,
rien à
voir avec.
But okay, here's the
continuation of the Rue de
Rivoli which had been begun by
Napoleon and it gives you major
access,
that is west/east,
and as we'll see in a minute he
also creates a north/south
access because--or axis,
what am I saying?;
well, access, the same thing.
So, that just gives you kind of
a view from the top.
And here are these les
halles, this is the old
market that was there.
And I was lucky because it was
gone about two years later or
something like that.
And I met a person who was kind
enough to lodge me,
and to take me down to see
that.
And it's just gone.
Now they have yet another plan
to do something,
and it's just become this--oh
well, ugh.
Okay, so again bringing-
freeing the flow of capital,
of commerce,
et cetera,
et cetera was a worthy goal
indeed, and one of the things
that Napoleon III did was to
celebrate France with these
expositions.
And of course the idea of
having a big exposition is that
of the Victorians,
the big one in 1851 at the
Crystal Palace.
The first public toilets,
by the way, as such things
were, in 1851 in London.
And, so, Louis Napoleon has
other expositions.
This one is 1854.
And, so, the principle of this
is you walk down one of these
exposition halls and you look
and you see paintings on the
right,
you see the wonders of science
on the left, et cetera,
et cetera;
and millions of people go.
And that's the same principle
as the department store,
isn't it, except that you can
buy what you see.
And the department stores,
what they do is they destroy
local commerce,
unless-- like boot makers and
very skilled craftsmen are on
the boulevards near the
department stores,
or provide essential services
in working class districts.
So, the Grand Magasin du Louvre
is here, you've all the space,
it becomes as Zola said the
"cathedral of modernity," along
with the others.
Now, there are the equivalent
of department stores in Paris in
some of the arcades already in
the 18--not arcades in our
sense,
but the arcades in the Parisian
sense--in the 1820s,
and there are even sort of
proto department stores exist
before that.
But it's the '50s and '60s that
brings to London,
and to Vienna,
and to Berlin,
and to Paris the department
store, where you could buy forty
different kinds of shawls,
cheap shawls to very fancy
shawls.
So, it's going to attract not
only ordinary people looking
occasionally for bargains.
And, as I said before,
it's a form of--it creates jobs
for working class and peasant
women who becomes sales clerks
living in terrible conditions in
kind of dormitories and almost
prison-like rules;
but it also brings the
friqué,
the wealthy people will come in
their carriages and have their
drivers await them when they go
in and listen to people sing
Christmas carols on the stairs.
And when electricity becomes
common in the 1880s and 1890s
you have these dazzling displays
that change in the--along the
streets,
and so they become really a
site of tourism themselves.
And, so, here your basic idea
is to create--the problem is how
do you get from--this is north,
this is south,
and this is east,
this is west--that there was no
way of getting anywhere.
The two biggest streets in
Paris in terms of the most
important ones were the Rue
Saint-Denis and the Rue
Saint-Martin--please don't
remember these names.
And, so, what they do is they
create the Boulevard
Saint-Michel,
which is a disaster,
here, and then--because
McDonald's and all this stuff,
just awful, just terrible
zoning;
and then here,
what became the Boulevard
Sebastopol, the Boulevard
Saint-Denis that goes out to the
railroad stations.
And, of course,
Haussmann is often castigated
for having built the railroad
stations next to each other,
without having anticipated the
automobile, but how could he
have known about the automobile
in the 1850s and '60s?
So, they complete the sort of
star, the Étoile here,
which is the place,
place of the Arc de
Triomphe, and creates--he
finishes the Rue de Rivoli here,
and of course it's along that
axis, as you saw,
that the troops come in May of
1851,
decimating those who resisted
in these neighborhoods.
So, those are basically the
plans that he wanted to do.
So, here we go.
This is the Rue de Rivoli,
this is down its sort of
completion, this is heading
east,
and the troops move down this
way, and that,
it just parallels the Seine.
This is the tower,
the remaining part of the
tour of Saint-Jacques
that is there.
And, then, now this is looking
north and you're crossing
Cité now.
This is where the police were,
at the Châtelet in the
eighteenth century.
But the point is that you see
in the distance the Station of
the East, the Gare de l'est.
And so he's very successful.
In many ways he's not an
interesting man,
Haussmann.
I was asked to write a
biography of him once and I
didn't do it,
I gave it to someone else.
And of course Paris is the big
story.
He was a fonctionnaire,
he was a technocrat,
but he was very good at what he
did, from repress people to
building boulevards.
And, so, this is a success
there, it frees up the flow of
circulation, but it chases
people like this--this is a pawn
shop that still exists,
it's a municipal pawnshop,
it's exactly the same space
where it was at this time.
And anyone who looked at this
would know what the image is,
because these people are so
poor they are about to sell back
their mattress.
Remember what I said in
L'Assommoir that Gervaise
dies like a dog on a bed of
straw, more or less.
The last dignity that you had
was to still have a mattress,
and when things got so bad that
was what went,
the mattress.
And so these folks are tearing
out--carrying mattresses to try
to get what they can from them.
And then you've got the very
poor down-and-out being expelled
to the periphery even more.
This is a place where people
could get a little bit of food
from charitable organizations.
This is in Montmartre.
And I just put this in,
it's around the corner actually
from our apartment,
but this is a classic kind of
Haussmann building,
and architects had started to
sign their work on the
première
étage,
on the second floor.
So, this architect was called
David and it has the date there.
And these balconies are more
ornate, really,
than the ones that they did in
general, at the time of
Haussmann.
These are more sort of Third
Republic ones.
But these are some very
handsome buildings that
lined--this is that line of
boulevard that lines the Rue du
Temple.
Now, and here we've got--this
is cracked, I'm sorry--but this
is the Station of the East.
And when I see the station it
always gives me a twinge of
sadness because in 1914 all the
people charging up to the
station,
screaming, "à
Berlin, à
Berlin," "to Berlin,
to Berlin,"
and this is one of the,
along with the Station of the
North, led the troops to the
fronts,
from which many of
them--most--well,
many of them,
a million and a half never
returned.
And also so many,
from these stations,
so many Jews were rounded up by
the Germans,
but above all by the French
police, in 1942 and 1943 were
sent on their way to Drancy,
to the transit camp north of
Paris, and then on to the death
camps.
And again one of the themes is
that all of this makes this
west/east division even more
salient,
and makes the center periphery
contrast or juxtaposition even
more important.
Louis-Napoleon has spent a lot
of time in London.
He loved parks and so he has
them work on the Bois de
Boulogne, to the west of Paris,
fancy, feeding the--or
receiving people from the
fancier quarters.
And these kinds of
cafés-concert
along the Champs
Élysées are part
again of this east/west
dichotomy.
And, then, that's not to say
that there weren't parks in the
east.
This is the Butte de Chaumont,
which is to the east,
and there's--apparently a lot
of real high stakes boule
games are still played here.
So, there were places.
Paris has very little green
space compared to London and
Berlin.
Berlin, twenty-five percent of
Berlin is green space and
London's about the same thing;
Paris it's five percent.
And, then, there's the Bois de
Vincennes which is out to the
east as well.
But here is again--this is your
image of the Belle
Époque.
Here you've got carriages
carrying fancy people along,
you have the kiosks selling
newspapers,
you have trees,
you have these boulevards that
had been created by Haussmann.
Now, to be sure now there were
boulevards in European cities
before Haussmann.
They tended to be on the
outskirts of cities,
and they were built where there
had been walls,
military fortifications,
in a way replaced ramparts that
had been torn down.
The best example,
and many of you may know this,
is Vienna with the Ringstrasse,
which was really a creation of
the liberal period in Viennese
history, in the 1850s,
and '60s, and '70s,
and which was on where there
had been fortified walls.
And in the case of Paris the
best example is Montparnasse.
Boulevard Montparnasse is on
where there had been military
fortifications but,
as Paris expanded,
the fortifications had to keep
being pushed out.
So, this is the Boulevard
Montmartre here in 1900,
and then the next one is the
slide that--it will be a color
picture--and this is Pissarro's
view of that same boulevard.
And my great friend Bob
Herbert, the fantastic social
historian of art,
actually found the place where
Pissarro was looking out the
window to do this.
Here again, it's an obvious
theme, but the light and the
movement and the first painting,
what strikes you at the first
glance, Paris was really,
the Paris of the boulevards
were really made for the
Impressionist paintings.
And the only working-class
impressionist painter was
Renoir, and it was Renoir whom I
quoted the other day.
He started out as a porcelain
painter in Limoges,
painting porcelain,
and it was he that said that
these boulevards reminded him of
the soldiers lined up for
review.
Again, that's not a bad
description of the imperialism
of the straight line.
But it was these boulevards,
and its commerce,
and its wealthy people that the
anarchists so much hated.
And again here,
this is a place,
and this is--I threw this in
for people that know something
about Impressionist
paintings--this became an
Impressionist painting,
and I didn't get the slide,
kind of an important street or
intersection because the
Impressionist collector and
painter Caillebotte did his
Paris,
the Effect of the
Rain, where he has bourgeois
couples crossing the street,
near each other,
but having nothing in common
with each other,
part of the anomie of the city;
and it was a statement about
the sort of self-importance of
the middle class.
And some of Caillebotte's other
paintings involve views from
balconies in which the person
is--the viewer or the main
subject of the painting is
isolated from ordinary people
who might walk around below.
And you can over-emphasize his
themes too much but it's still
worth keeping in mind.
But here you have your basic
Impressionist landscape,
and it was very much a creation
of the rebuilding of Paris in
the 1850s and '60s,
urban landscape.
So, again, this is a great
example of the way in which not
all boulevards were created by
the Alsatian Attila in Paris.
Some, as I suggested a few
minutes ago, followed the routes
of the walls,
and here's the best example one
could pick.
This was, at the time of the
French Revolution,
the city limits.
The two gates like this were
called the Porte Saint-Denis and
the Porte Saint-Martin.
And it was when Louis XVI and
Marie Antoinette tried to
escape, and probably disguised
as retainers for some wealthy
baroness,
they were able to get through
this particular gate because the
guards were
bourrés,
they were all drunk from having
been at a wedding.
And then the tax collected on
what you brought into the city
passed right through this gate.
You had to pay a tax on what
you brought into the city,
more about that in a minute.
But you can see that these
boulevards become extensions of
these walls that had once been
there.
And in the case of the Porte
Saint-Martin and the Porte
Saint-Denis, they are still
there.
And of course the Porte
Saint-Denis is going north to
the cathedral town of
Saint-Denis,
or village of Saint-Denis,
or small town,
which became an important
center of working class
production,
and subsequently of anarchism,
socialism, and ultimately
communism, more about that in a
minute.
Now, you still have traditional
work done in Paris,
as I suggested when we were
talking about the garment
industry,
and you still had cases where
the father is literally the
foreman, and his family is
working for him,
through sub-contracting,
people working at what was a
rather large--no,
this is an atelier,
this is not their home--well,
you got pots and things hanging
around, a big roof.
But, anyway,
it's in the eastern part of
Paris, and in the northeastern,
and in the suburbs that you've
got the conversion of old
buildings into industrial
production,
and you have new industries
perched on the edge of the city.
And this is the rue,
the faubourg of
Saint-Antoine which at the time
of the French Revolution was
beyond the Bastille,
and it was lots of these people
who were cabinet workers who
stormed the Bastille in 1789;
but again the contrast between
center and periphery.
This is a somewhat sympathetic
but also a little bit
condescending look at popular
sociability in these cabarets
that I talked about the other
day,
on the edge of--the perception,
middle class perception of the
drunken commoner perched on the
edge of urban life,
on the margins of urban life,
drinking it up.
And these are really great.
I put these next two in simply
to show you the difference
between--or give you images of
the difference between what
happens to the western districts
of Paris,
on the edge,
and those of the east.
Now, this is the east,
on the very edge,
and these are sort of rural
looking houses,
with slanted roofs like that.
This is the laundry of combat,
so this is a real kind of
socialist image from the turn of
the century.
This has got to be right before
World War I.
How do we know that?
Because this is something of
the métro,
and the first metro opened
along the Seine,
paralleling the Seine,
on July 14th,
1900, for the exhibition;
it's now the line that goes to
Île-de-France all the way
out to Vincennes,
to the east.
And then the lines were
subsequently extended out.
So, this is probably about
1912,1913.
But this is still kind of
a--these are industrial suburbs
that have been created by both
the industrial conglomeration of
Paris,
the availability of land and of
capital on the outside of Paris,
and of a workforce,
of a very transient but still
massive workforce there.
And then if we go off in the
other direction,
on the edge-- and this would be
what the equivalent now of the
seventeenth arrondissement--I
reversed this but it doesn't
make the slightest bit of
difference--you see that this
building is sort of a solidly
artisanal,
lower-middle-class building
that reflects the fact that in
many ways the western half of
Paris,
including even the western
periphery, was very different.
I say that with some--once you
get the image that all the
suburbs in the west were like
Versailles, Argenteuil for
example.
Five people broke into the
Musée d'Orsay over the
weekend, and for some--whatever
reason,
they're all drunked up,
poked a big hole in Monet's
great The Bridge at
Argenteuil painting,
which is really kind of amazing
damage.
But Argenteuil was a place
where you had leisure,
you had sailboats,
you had people of means.
You no longer had vineyards at
all but you also had industry.
And Monet, the painter Claude
Monet, his depictions of
Argenteuil, you have the smoke
stacks become just part of the
scene and it's a very neutral
kind of look at smoke stacks,
not clearly differentiated even
from these sailboats,
sort of in the regattas and all
of that.
But Monet, as my friend Bob
Herbert, who pointed this out,
Monet when he lives at
Argenteuil,
he gets tired of that,
he gets tired of kind of the
contradictions of capitalism and
industrialization and he longs
for this non-urban
paysage,
this non-urban scenes to paint.
And what does he do?
As you all know he moves to
Giverny;
Giverny along the Seine,
and a railroad track runs right
through his backyard and he
never paints it,
not once.
What he does is he creates this
kind of idyllic rural scene of
lily pads and ponds.
And it's a wonderful experience
to go there, if you're not
trampled by the 40,000 tourists.
You can imagine this is
someplace where someone lived,
and ran up and down the stairs,
and had fun,
and then went out and got away
from the sort of industry of
Argenteuil.
But, anyway,
he was moving on to a different
stage.
And, so, what you get on the
edge of Paris,
the west, is this.
This is the Avenue of the
Grande Armée.
So this is beyond the Arc de
Triomphe.
And now this is going out to
Neuilly which is a very--right
on the edge of the Bois de
Boulogne,
which became a very,
very prosperous suburb,
and certainly still is,
that's for sure.
And what you had on the other
side of the east was very
different, in the north and
northeast was extremely
different, it wasn't like that
at all.
And, so, what happens when
you--the images that I showed
you before of those big arcs of
triumph that--in which you--in
which I said the king had
escaped through,
trying to get out of France
during the French Revolution.
And I said that you paid on
what you brought in.
And just in conclusion,
for the last seven minutes,
I'm going to talk a little bit
about a theme that's rather
interesting,
and that's why European suburbs
are so different than American
suburbs--more about that in a
minute.
But the walls around Paris,
when they lost their military
purposes, still had a fiscal
purpose which was to provide a
means of collecting taxes on
what you brought into town.
And this wall,
or this taxing apparatus,
is called in French the
octroi,
o-c-t-r-o-i.
And I love these little
buildings.
You can see some near Nation,
Place de la Nation,
and other--in Thar-cor,
in the Loire,
there's a fantastic one,
you see them all over the
place, and they're just
beautiful.
Sometimes people live in them.
But this lasts,
this isn't something that
disappeared in 1850 or 1900,
it lasts till World War II.
And thus that's the big way
that municipalities were able to
raise any money at all,
since basically wealthy people
didn't pay taxes,
and that's why--it's a very
regressive tax,
it's like a huge sales tax,
and France is nothing if it's
not full of regressive taxes,
since the value-added tax is
twenty-one percent,
and on electronics and stuff
like that it's thirty-three
percent.
So, you're taxed on what you
buy, and since poor people have
less money to buy things it
really is totally unfair.
But the origins of this system
is in the octroi,
and this is one of those
actually fairly rare photos that
I know of,
of what it was like in your
sort of diligence,
your coach here.
This was called an
imperial because people
rode on the top,
and you're leaving Paris,
or you're entering Paris,
it doesn't matter at all,
but the point is that you were
controlled,
day or night,
when you went through.
And on the edge of Paris are
created these working-class
industrial suburbs that are
feared by the center,
and during the 1920s and 1930s
become major sources of support
for the Communist Party,
because people,
most of the people who lived
there were extremely badly
lodged,
and the Communists do very well
because of the mal-lotis,
that is people who are badly
lodged,
and they provide services to
poor working families that in
other municipalities simply one
did not have.
And if you go to something like
the Fête de
l'Humanité,
which is the big Communist
party,
every year, a big boom,
a big--which means a big party,
full of speeches and all of
that,
you could kind of go from one
booth and have your oysters in
the Finistère booth,
and then go have paella in the
Catalan booth,
and then have goat's cheese in
the Ardèche booth,
et cetera, et cetera,
and Beaujolais in the
Rhône booth,
et cetera, et cetera.
But the association between
working-class people on the edge
of--on the margins of the big
city and radical politics is
terribly important in the '20s
and '30s,
and even much later than that.
And this is a town called
Corbevoie, which is north of
Paris, and they all have streets
called something like the Rue
Maurice Thorez,
who was a miner who was a
leader of the Communist Party,
following the dictates of
Moscow,
alas, in the 1930s.
Many of them still have an
Avenue Jean Jaurès,
for obvious reasons.
But it's this growth of all of
these industrial suburbs that is
one of the important sort of
concomitants of large-scale
industrialization,
and the identification of the
urban periphery with industrial
work.
Many of the so-called dirty
industries, chemical production,
soap production,
things that smell,
are forced out of the center
and onto the periphery.
And so that's where the
factories are,
that's where the cheapest labor
is to be found--more about this
in just a second,
I'll just finish this off with
a Monet of Argenteuil;
again, this one does-it's not
the Pont d'Argenteuil,
if I'd had time I would have
gone to get that one,
the painting was just ripped by
vandals over the weekend.
But, again, the extension of
the sort of prosperity to the
west is obviously the Normand
coast because the turbo trains
are already going to the Normand
coast,
Deauville is not far away,
Etretat and these kinds of
places are there.
And so that's an extension of
this west/east dichotomy,
that people from eastern Paris
or from the northern suburbs are
not going to Deauville,
for the weekend,
they're not the kind of people
who are going to be painted by
Berthe Morisot.
But, so, these spacial
concomitants or aspects even
continue to the planting of the
Parisian flag on the Normand
coast;
and again, that's a subject for
another excellent book by my
friend Bob Herbert.
Now, I want to finish off,
I want to get some more light
so I can see you all.
How to do this,
how to do this in five minutes?
I'll do this in the following
way.
In 1991--was it 1991?
Or 1992, at the time of the
Rodney King riots,
was that 1992?
Rodney King was an
Afro-American in L.A.
and the police basically just
beat the hell out of him,
and they're acquitted,
and it led to some very
difficult times in Los Angeles,
with lots of riots and lots of
anger.
And we were doing,
a bunch of us,
an edited book on the Red
suburbs, on precisely this and
working class suburbs and their
sort of identification with
radical politics.
And people in France kept
asking me, they couldn't
understand the concept of
wealthy suburbs and impoverished
people,
minorities living in the center
of cities.
And finally they stopped--even
press, well I could write
something--not because of me,
but I just wrote something,
an epilogue,
trying to explain why it is
that in Europe things are
different.
Now, and it's not entirely so.
After all, Versailles was a
suburb.
In the early 1830s one of the
ministers of Louis-Philippe went
to him and said,
"Sir, these factories that
you're allowing the prefect of
police to tolerate on the edge
of the city,
will be the cord that wrings
our neck one day."
Fear of the periphery,
not fear of the center.
In 1831 and 1834,
Lyon, the suburb of the
Croix-Rousse,
the silk workers,
poured down the hill,
defending their rights,
with signs that said "Live Free
and Die Fighting," and the
middle-class National Guard set
up their guns to--right at the
edge of the city,
to keep the suburban people
from invading the center.
That's very,
very different,
isn't it?
Limoges the same thing,
they put up barricades,
the workers in the suburbs,
that differentiated their space
with the center.
It is amazing,
amazing kinds of continuity,
these sort of mutual fears.
In Detroit, in 1968,
when I was a kid,
or was it 1967,
I went to a Tiger game and we
came out of the Tiger game,
double-header with the Yankees,
and the city was on fire,
and it was the riots of
Detroit.
And much of Detroit is still
decimated, has never recovered
from that, never,
despite the Renaissance Center,
and the occasional success of
the Tigers, and all good things
like that.
And one of the suburbs of
Detroit tried at one point to
change the street patterns so
that they,
that is the poor people from
the center, could not come out
to Grosse Pointe,
or Farmington Hills,
or one of those elegant places.
And I remember that very,
very vividly.
Now, why did that all happen,
why?
And we talk--and two years ago
we had these big riots in France
in the suburbs,
and it began in
Clichy-sous-Bois,
and all over the place;
some were exaggerated and all
of that, and Sarkozy spun it out
of control by calling them scum,
the people that live on the
periphery, they're scum,
"racaille,
ils existent,
la racaille," and all this
stuff.
It was just pas possible.
How did this happen?
What happened is that the
people unwanted by the center
were--and Haussmann was part of
this--rejected toward the
outside where,
with the dilapidation of
American center cities--a good
part of Philadelphia,
most of Detroit,
New Orleans,
San Francisco and Beacon Hill,
and we can find exceptions to
that--but the pattern is just
completely different.
You had the Viennese Army
firing large shells at the
working class suburbs,
at the working-class housing on
the outside of the city.
It's just the opposite.
When you think of suburbs you
don't just think of Darien or
you don't just think of Grosse
Pointe,
or Hillsborough,
California, or very fancy
places in other places.
But it's very different,
and the pattern is just the
opposite, just an incredible
difference.
One can exaggerate this too
much, but these spatial tensions
count for something,
and the margins of urban life
in France, and particularly
around Paris were really--the
periphery became the domain of
people who really couldn't
afford to live in the center.
And that's an increasing
problem in Paris today is one
neighborhood after another
becomes more and more expensive.
Now it's the^( )eleventh and
twelfth are out of control,
the^( )thirteenth is out of
control.
And three million people may
live in Paris,
but you've got another eight
thousand people living in this
urban agglomeration,
and creating these attempted
cities that are going to be
magnets of their own;
it's been an utter,
utter failure.
But Haussmann was really part
of that.
And people building factories
seek a labor force,
they seek more space,
they want to have their
factories outside of the customs
barrier,
so they're not paying taxes on
what they bring in to use in
their factory.
So, that's just a very short
explanation for why European
cities, and European suburbs in
particular,
the whole sense of a
suburb--despite the kind of
pavillon of
Saint-Remy-les-Chevreuse and
places like that in the sort of
wealthier parts of the Parisian
periphery,
there's still a contrast there.
And even the image when you
say, in French you say,
you come from the
quatre-vingt-treize,
you come from ninety-three,
that means Seine-Saint-Denis,
and that--for them that's the
image of the ninety-three
license plate is that of the
periphery,
of people who are thought to be
marginal by the center.
But, as I've argued in other
places, including some of my own
writing, the sense of not
belonging to the center creates
a type of solidarity that helped
the communists in the 1920s and
'30s,
and hopefully helped people,
as the government has undercut
the attempts of suburban people
to create voluntary associations
that will offer hope to all
these people.
Wait till you watch La
Haine, the film,
later on, it's incredible.
Well, some of this starts with
Haussmann.
We went a long way today,
from the Alsatian Attila all
the way to Clichy-sous-Bois,
two years ago.
But I hope that the larger
points were clear.
And from that we move on to
imperialism on Monday,
have a fantastic weekend.
See ya.